you obviously being associated with
being the the lean guy yeah i was a
juice man
um
you know i i know the first rapper that
i saw
kind of come out
and someone who i knew every time i
would see was that was [ __ ] high off
his ass was mozzie
mozzie did the kick the cup [ __ ] right
yeah
and um
i know some people were like man that's
corny whatever but i thought it was dope
but i remember when you posted that
i was like this is big man because you
got you got a whole different grip on
some of these kids and the way they look
up to you
and i know that that's not an easy thing
to stay off of them i'm not saying you
people don't people don't relapse they
don't [ __ ] up or because that's a hard
it's just bigger than like like whether
you do it or you don't the biggest part
is not to do it in the public eye not to
glorify you right yeah like not to like
like honestly bro i could sit right here
take a picture promoting my album do
whatever promoted my clothes
it'll do
whatever to do now if i was to put a
bottle of lean
a double cup or actually put me pouring
the lean while i'm telling something i'm
gonna get more you might do more 300 400
000 more views than then percent more
views than the regular one but the thing
again is like bro like i'm not just
trying to like you know i got brothers
so when i see my little brother pouring
up you know spending his money on trying
to sip and it's like these kids don't
know what they doing they can they're
grabbing anything and just pouring it in
a soda
so that's when i kind of stepped back
from just like you know glorifying it or
like putting it out there you know what
i mean